welcome back to New Rockstars it's me Mt
and we gotta talk about it y'all we've
gotta talk about the big quantumania
elephant in the room and no I'm not
talking about giant Scott and Cassie
because that would be rude and they're
both way too hot to be elephants let's
be real but oh no today I am here to ask
the question that we've all been
wondering ever since we all watched the
Abraham the Lost quantumania did Janet
bang the king did a cheater Pfeiffer
pick canes pickled pepper well I like
many other people on the internet
definitely think they totally did do the
quantum adultery but let's get into why
I believe this shall we my fellow nosy
nerd babies but first you guys know that
I'm always rocking this hoodie because
this is my favorite freaking piece of
new rockstars Merchants our new hang
hoodie from nerd riot.shop it is so
freaking dope along with our other
quantumanian spotted merch and we're
just starting to get our new Mandalorian
inspired merch the shirts are really
dope I freaking love these designs so
nerdrive.shop is your One Stop Shop for
all things nerd so shop today all right
gang it's time for the question did
Janet engage in the quantum gang bang
after they spent all their time together
well you can just call my ass yes Steve
Harvey because I reached I recently
conducted a survey of 100 people well
there was actually 25 100 people 20 2500
people and apparently eighty percent of
you believe that Janet became very
familiar with all seven of Kang's holes
in the quantum realm through the quantum
sin of adultery and I don't blame you
all because I too have seen Ant-Man in
the wasp quantumania and I too know that
Janet Van Dyne and Kang spent a lot of
time together in the quantum realm
outside of time I mean Janet literally
said the word ages when referring to how
long it took for them to repair his
and I mean Kang's crash ship was not
going to repair itself I mean he would
think it would considering that it was
from the future but whatever and being
the only Earthling that Janet was ever
going to stumble across for a long while
in this strange new place it makes sense
that these two would become extremely
close in more fun ways than one as
Janet's relationship with Kang was
probably the strongest bond that she had
in the quantum realm ever because while
yeah the quantum realm apparently is
home to a lot of human-like beings like
krylar Oz and gentora but none of them
really had a shared knowledge of Earth
history and a passion for Quantum
science like Kang did and I think Janet
really did feel that disconnect between
those people too even saying in the
movie that after so many years alone it
was nice to have a friend in K but not
only this but Kang and Janet were both
Quantum scientists with a passion for
Learning and Discovery and in the movie
Janet says that King introduced himself
as a scientist and a traveler and in her
words she had never met anyone like him
and that he felt lost how do you know
that he felt lost huh most people would
say he seemed a lot which felt more lost
his pecs or his abs Janet tell me and
she says this right after shots of them
smiling at each other and Kang almost
going to bite his thumb when he looks at
her like come on now the implication was
so strong here like so strong and while
I do realize that Janet does note that
they were only friends that don't mean
that they can't be friends with benefits
you know what I'm saying especially when
a hot black and mysterious Quantum
scientist literally falls out of the sky
after years of not having your sexual
and physical needs addressed and in the
movie we learn that this is something
that Hank was more than fine with his
wife doing after he discovered that she
had a brief fling with Bill Murray's
krylar character Hank being the
scientist that he is understood that his
wife still would have sexual needs in
the quantum realm much like he had his
own sexual needs in the big people world
and Hank was comfortable enough with
their own romantic bomb for one another
to know that any sexual contact that
they might have with someone outside of
their marriage would be purely to
fulfill their biological desire for
physical and sexual intimacy which is
why I believe Hank mentions having a
brief fling with a woman named Linda
back in the day but that relationship
not really going anything beyond the
physical because at the end of the day
Linda's touch wasn't as appealing as
Janet's look which is quite romantic in
its own way but speaking of this
mysterious Linda that Hank had passed
relations with I have a feeling that
this revelation of Hank Pym also having
extra marital Partners could be the MCU
teasing the coming of not one but two
new Marvel heroes but first of all let's
talk about Linda because I have a
feeling that Hank and name dropping
Linda could be Marvel's second time
teasing the coming of Marvel's Night
Nurse to the MCU because check this out
gang Hank was active as a superhero in
the 70s and 80s fighting various Wars
and doing science stuff at Camp Lehigh
with Howard Stark right and it's during
the 80s in one of these War missions
that Hank lost Janet to the quantum
realm but also during the 80s that a
mysterious nurse would let a certain
Isaiah Bradley free from his 30 years of
experimentation by the military he took
pity on me wrote up some fake reports
something she had me declared dead I
think this military nurse who took pity
on Isaiah Bradley's experimentation and
helped him Escape was the same Linda
that Hank had a brief fling with Linda
Carter the Night Nurse and this would
also make sense considering that
apparently according to the showrunner
for Netflix's Daredevil the show
originally had Rosario Dawson's Claire
Temple as Linda Carter the night nurse
but was told by Marvel Studios
themselves to change that name to a
different name because they had plans
for a Linda Carter Night Nurse down the
road which is why she is called Claire
Temple instead so I think those Marvel
Studios plans for the night nurse are
starting to come true with both Falcon
and Winter Soldier and now with Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania both teasing
the coming of Linda but also knowing
that Hank was doing the hanky-panky
himself also opens the door for another
strong Marvel heroine Nadia Van Dyne aka
the Unstoppable wasp who in the comics
is the long-lost daughter of Heng Pym
who got wrapped up in the red room of
widows before being freed and becoming
the next wasp I think Marvel telling us
about Hank's sexual past was more than
just a joke I think that doing this so
soon after the Red Room was just
canonically liberated by Natasha in the
Black Widow film is very much preparing
the Marvel audience to meet Miss Nadia
down the line maybe even possibly as the
secret daughter of Linda Carter's Night
Nurse who knows that'd be a nice little
twist from the comics but anyways this
all being said with full confidence that
her husband would respect her sexual
health and needs I am also confident
that Kang and Janet did do the deed at
least one time at least one time at
least like Janet went from being
stranded alone not talking to anyone to
telling this Quantum traveler that fell
from the sky nearly everything about her
life and family like Kang even knew the
nickname that Janet had for Hope like he
literally called hope Harold Jelly Bean
a Quantum scientist who also happened to
be a traveler like her husband if her
husband was also black it had his body
chiseled by Apollo himself like Kang and
Janet totally boned they totally did
this sex because let's be real here
Janet Van Dyne kinda has a thing for
I mean first she married Hank
then she banged Kang and then she banged
kreiler like she's like a douchebag
magnet but yes you're welcome I asked
the one question that we all had on our
minds did Janet Bank hang and they
totally did I think they totally did
Kang is literally just a more handsome
version of her husband let's be real but
anyways thank you guys for watching this
video you can follow me at mastertonment
on Twitter if you guys want to see me
tweet some weird and really fun
theories but more importantly you can
follow new rockstars wherever we are on
the social medias and of course do not
forget to hit up nerd riot.shop where
you can pick up one of these amazing new
quantumania inspired hoodies we also got
mandalorians fired hoodies coming very
soon and of course do not forget to
subscribe to the Deep dive where we are
going into movies a lot more deeper than
usual on that YouTube channel it's
really great go subscribe to the Deep
time today but anyways thank you guys so
much for watching this video again I
love you guys so much and I'll see you
guys next time goodbye and go bang a
Kang today if you can if you came
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you